you'd always make a date for the fa cup
final you know so to
get to a position where you you win it
and see my dad and go like oh my god you
know we've done it and then when i had
the cup in my hand
looking up to him like you know think of
the history and the people that have had
their hands on it or the the games that
we've watched together me as a as a kid
and
him as my dad and then for me to finally
hold it was
yeah it's amazing and emotional and
yeah i just got hammered
[Music]
when you were a young player first
breaking through
do you remember any specific advice you
were given by a fellow pro
yeah there was a few technical bits i
always remember uh
tottenham
les ferdinand was always very very good
to me so like
things with less like people think less
is like six four he's probably about six
foot just touching six foot um and i was
six foot seven
and not very good in the air
which was not ideal so les
taught me how to head of football taught
me how to jump taught me how to get away
from defenders
taught me how to
be more dominant in the air
there was there was no one better i used
to watch less at qpr
and he was he was brilliant is it quite
intimidating meeting people because you
watched les you said qpr and stuff is it
kind of like intimidating to be like
i looked up to you
um it is yeah i think you've got to get
over that i think uh so certainly when i
first sort of trained with the first
team or
was around the players um
i was a bit anxious and like oh my god
look i was training with david genola
and les ferdinand people like soul
campbell
can you tell us the story story of you
being a star struck when you met when
you met your nola for the first time
when i went to nola which i was on
janola's boots so i used to clean
gelato's boots the year that he won the
player of the year he was off the charts
um i always remember what genoa said to
me once i was i was we did a finishing
session
trying to think it was myself chris
armstrong stephan everson
and janola
and then
when the ball was getting clipped out
there
clipped up back to me and i was i was
like just like kept moving and like kept
he was like he said whoa whoa
and he just said why why why are you
like why are you moving so much
and i i was just getting ready i was
getting my toes like ready for the ball
he said no no no he said just relax and
then i always remember it the ball got
chipped out he flicked it up
volleyed it in the top corner he said
like this
why can't i be more like that
god that has to be saw on bro oh man the
little ponytail flew the other way and
he just smashed in the top corner
bearing in mind liverpool have just won
the european cup in possibly the best
final that we've ever seen right in
istanbul i was sat there watching now i
remember i was a way of england with joe
cole and um we were watching it i just
thought it was unbelievable like
incredible and little did i know like a
few months later i'd be playing for that
team you know so i was sitting i always
remember it my agent called me and i was
at home and he said he's sitting down
and i was like yeah
liverpool want you and i was you know
couldn't couldn't believe it i'd had an
amazing season at southampton but
um i i just thought liverpool are the
pick of
the europe's best strikers you know and
um
you know and rafford seen something in
me that he liked and
i was on my way up there and then
obviously
always remember me and my dad sort of
you know we're football people so going
around
anfield and looking at the history and
the trophies and
the players that have walked in that in
that stadium before
just incredible to be a part of it there
was a lot to iron out because i was at
southampton at the time we'd been
relegated and
rupert lowe was the chairman at the time
and he was quite adamant that i'd be
staying um i had to go into pre-season
so it was in
i mean it dragged on for quite a while
uh i ended up having to drive down to
rupert lowe's house and um because he
wasn't answering calls
and i said to him what
you want me to play in the champions
league in the championship or the
champions league next year you know i
mean like if you put yourself in my
shoes and obviously i've got an
opportunity to go to liverpool and he
was like yeah but we need you to get
back up you can always go next year and
i was like look listen it might not be
it won't be happening next year so i was
quite adamant obviously that i wanted to
wanted to go but um and harry was
obviously my major at the time was
probably playing both sides he was
saying to me yeah you've got to go
absolutely got to and then saying to
rupert now we've got to keep him
you said before behind that they were
the training was a different level
liverpool where it was like the steven
yard was
always on it
was it incredible to just being training
with players of that level of ability
yeah i think um
you know having trained with with
england
while i was at southampton obviously
that you know gave me uh
you know
an inkling into what playing at top club
would be like you know day in day out
because the standards expected and uh
like i say it's quite ruthless so
when uh the ball was wrapped into me by
steven gerrard like i'm expected to
control it and if one bounced off you
you get the stare from stevie's if like
what am i dealing with you know
you say you don't want to let you always
didn't want to let stephen down more
more than you didn't want to let rafa
down so
it was intense training um and to the
level you would expect
from a top club and i'd say that stevie
was there any is there who else was
there in this world that you were like
wow that's that's a player defensively
at that time we were
we were brilliant um hoopier and
carriger center halves were it did just
you just felt totally confident
with them there
uh but yeah the midfield was
was frightening as well like with uh
with alonso gerard later mascarano soco
like the central midfield players were
were off the charts as well um steve
finland was one of the most underrated
players i think i've ever played with
and then eventually when torres came um
he just
you know he just blew it away
while we're on tours there then like
when that happens when someone arrived
like tourists right later on when you've
been there for a year or so and
when his first training session is kind
of like
a player um
would you believe if i said no
thing is about turrets
i don't know we you have a probably a
preconception of spanish players being
very sort of technically gifted um
he he wasn't really a traditional
spanish player if you know what i mean
so in training like i wouldn't say like
it was
you know his first touch was brilliant
and like you know
he's hating you know games and things
like that but come the game he was so
explosive
um strong quick and and could finish and
he had the ability to sort of you know
twist people inside out and um and
finish and he was so strong he was quite
nasty like you know it wasn't something
that i expected he would be um obviously
i'd seen him play for athletico but when
he came he was something different to
what i expected um but but my god when
he when he played that season it was it
was a joke he was just he was tearing
defenses apart
you know when torres came in i was like
yeah great you know i've got a top
player here where am i going to fit into
this and then obviously torres and
stevie sort of hit it off with an
amazing like understanding and then i
was basically the plan b then which i've
got totally like you know i can't stand
there and go i should be playing ahead
of toros who's back 30 the year before
um but i i was in a good good form
myself i think i scored 18 goals the
year before um you know i'd scored a lot
of goals in the champions league i was
playing for england scoring for fun as
well and i felt like that you know him
coming which i totally understand it so
you know it was halting what i was doing
you know i couldn't really
i couldn't stand by and let that happen
you know i had an ignorant place at
stake and i was gutted
um
leaving liverpool because i would have i
would have i'd like to have been there
for the rest of my life but i just
couldn't see a way that i
me and and unless me and torres played
together which i thought we could have
done
but raphael didn't seem to
you know in
do that much
so yeah i felt like i had to move on
it's a shame really because i ended up
seeing gog environment up front instead
perhaps you should have hung around
did you have like did you have a
relationship with rafa where like
you could go and tell him like can i
can i start with should i be playing on
top of tourism you know what no one had
a relationship with referee like that um
i don't think he didn't enjoy anyone
sort of coming to question in some of
his decisions and often if you said
something to him
and asked him about decisions and you
know
where can i improve or what can i do he
just dropped you for three four games
he was very very cold in in that in
those situations there you'd just be
like you'd never know what he was
thinking ever i remember stephen gerald
quite famously saying that he never got
well done
from rafa he would always i remember
stevie running games coming in
afterwards and rapha would tell him
where he went wrong
and you're thinking right you know it'd
always be
how you could improve
and never
you know well done you played well today
i always remember i think it was a game
at birmingham city we played i scored
two before half time and i said to
raffle like
let me stay on i want to get hat tricks
and all that he hauled me off in 54
minutes
or straight off
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i was i was quite nervy
if i remember rightly i mean what the
definer wasn't at wembley it was in
cardiff so we were uh we stayed in hotel
and there was there would
things would wouldn't play like
for liverpool like in the champions
league or in an fa cup final for
instance you can't get away from nipples
they're everywhere right they just
they're just everywhere no matter where
you are they'll they'll find you um so i
remember being hotel there was loads of
fans downstairs they were singing songs
they were
you know it was all going and you so you
just you can't really like
just pretend it's a another game
um
and i was quite nervy because i i've
grown up with the fa cup and that was my
i'd always wanted to win it and
i grew up not far from wembley so i
watched a load of finals and
um
it was special yeah the fact like i
found out i was starting i was
really
really pleased with um
you know ordered you know all the new
boots printed up with the
the the fa cup final sort of on the boot
and stuff like that so they were all
lined up it was just you could just feel
like it was a bigger game than
than normal
and then the game was
an incredible match it was amazing you
were either an assistant from jail i did
yeah yeah i scored a goal that i've
still maintained up until this day that
was on site um
but having looked you know in the var
era
if i had to i think i was off
i'll get to my end zone
it was so close though and i was like
you know it was a good i would love to
have scored the final obviously but
um yeah that was one that got away but
uh yeah i remember i wouldn't really
call an assist i just nodded one down
and
stevie hit one 35 yards
yeah you couldn't miss from there
that's something and then you've got all
that like if you were you're in
something after about 70 minutes when i
think yeah for for didi haman then um
you're watching on the sidelines
watching this game get
what's the feel is the difference in
feeling between being on the pitch and
then watching it from the sidelines yeah
worse miles worse when you when all got
sobbed off it was miles worse but i
remember obviously being down i remember
halftime team talk and we were losing
and the
i don't know if you remember at that
time west ham and padre had all been
dancing right you know every every game
that like when they were winning they
would have a little dance together and
all that and i remember the team talk
was like we just don't want to see these
dancing
and uh
yeah i mean it rails stevie
no one wants to see parties
especially not steven by looks at it
uh because i remember yeah cramp just
before he hit the
the the the equalizer he had cramp and
i was on and everyone was going you know
we need to get him off we need to get
him off and then
he well it wasn't long after he was down
he got up and then hit this shot
from that far out
with cramp
it you know it defies the fire's logic
but that for me
winning the fa cup and you know it
wasn't one yet after that strike but
it felt like
our name was on the cup if you're not i
mean it's a cliche but it really did
went because because we were down and
out and
you know he's hit this it was like one
last effort to to shoot from 25 yards
and um yeah we saw that go in he was
just like you know this fella's
superhuman was just like pandemonium on
the benches there carnage absolute
carnage and then it was like right calm
down we've got more work to do i mean
the moment we won it i just think yeah
it's relief more than anything because
because the way the game panned out we
did the ups and downs of the game and
yeah we just we were just
tired we were remote i was quite
emotional i remember running on the
pitch and throwing my jacket around and
little things like that and then seeing
my dad and become quite emotional about
that whole situation because
because of
the fa cup meant so much to me and my
dad it was like our thing you know like
watching
the gate that was the biggest you'd
always make a date for the fa cup final
you know so to
get to a position where you you win it
and see my dad and go like oh my god you
know we've done it and then when i had
the cup in my hand
looking up to him like you know think of
the history and the people that have had
their hands on it or the the games that
we've watched together me as a as a kid
and and him as my dad and then for me to
finally hold it was
yeah it's amazing and emotional and
yeah i just got hammered
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know one thing that sticks out in my
mind um was the champions league final
in 2007. and just not starting that game
like i felt like i'd scored a lot of
goals i'd done well and then to not be
selected for the final was a was a
killer personally because obviously i
never got the chance to play in the
champions league final again i did come
on you know but you know i felt like
that actually was there for the taking
and we
we let them off the hook a bit there is
is that the hardest loss to take in your
career as well that final yeah i think
so because we i i think we were a good
team then
um and we didn't really take the game to
them
um we played like dirk quite up front on
his own five in midfield and
i felt like they were
not as good as the 2005 team that got
beat um
they're still obviously top side but i
just felt if we did if we'd have been
more
offensive i think we could have gone and
beaten them and uh like i say it would
have it would have been nice to have a
champions league winners middle instead
of a runner's up one which i don't even
know where it is really
do you keep all your other medals yeah
i've got medals and stuff yeah all the
winners ones are all kept somewhere yeah
i just i just i like that one i don't
think i ever look i think i've looked at
it since i
since i lost since we lost
not once
[Music]
he played under sven and steve mclaren
and capello is that like what were their
strengths and weaknesses what were they
who what were they how are they
different yeah i mean chalk and cheese
really sven and fabio um you know sven
was so relaxed really you know chilled
out and that his kind of approach suited
me the the most i felt
because
you just let you go out and play and
express yourself and
say you you know you're good players go
and basically
show how good you are whereas yeah fabio
was was completely the opposite you know
in a structure you stay to this
structure you know the discipline the
much less relaxed let's be honest um but
that was it that was his style but but
for me personally that that didn't work
for me as much
um
but mclaren was sort of in between that
really and i felt like you know i know
he gets a bit of a rough ride with
with england fans maybe and uh but as a
as a coach and as a as a help to me
uh he was first class um i felt
you know we'd known him beforehand
anyway because he was he was a terrific
coach he was around the lads lads all
respected him um and yeah we had a
difficult time because we didn't qualify
in 2008 for the euros
and he got a hell of a lot of stick
which england managers do but um
from inside the camp everyone had you
know nothing but respect for him i want
to talk about fabio capello being a
disciplinarian because i've heard i've
heard ben foster all talking about how
he had very he's very strict on
everything what was that like as a camp
when you're with them for a long time
well it was difficult it was quite funny
seeing seeing some senior players
getting told off for the first time
frank lampard for being on his phone um
it was like being a naughty
you know we felt like we were with kids
again you know but i found it quite
funny when you know like
players of
the caliber of players that were getting
cold off was quite funny i remember
emily getting there
he was um
what did he do again oh yeah he was on
his phone in uh
at dinner and i remember you know when
you lift off the trays of the buffet and
i remember just throwing the train the
noise that it made like
these trays the buffet going down right
and he said emil
i'm looked after
we have we have 10 minutes to stick
together um
with no fire and you can't do it and uh
he threw them again and the noise and it
ricocheted all around the room and then
always remember that i'm just putting it
away like sorry
were you ever ever on the end of a
uh
yeah i remember he taught me you know i
mean i already came to a game um in into
milan we played at what harlem
uh
and he never really really
but he uh i remember
i felt like i was good at volleys i
remember him telling me like he came in
after five minutes and told me that my
volume technique was wrong and then i
said i'll be honest i know that he's an
absolute legend i've got a lot of
respect for you but i've been volley
like this all my life and i'm not going
to change it now
and yeah he was a bit taken back by that
but um
yeah i always remember that sort of one
uh and also yeah it completely mugged me
off for the um
for the south africa world cup 2010 gave
it to the number nine and gave me about
five minutes
i got a squad number i always remember
thinking oh my god i've got the number
nine for the world cup this is i'm
playing
i didn't play it at all
[Music]
i think representing my country like
every time it was never lost on me
really it was never lost on me
um
every time you played and i think
scoring my first goal was i played i was
at liverpool at the time and it was at
anfield against uruguay that was my
first goal um
there were some good moments obviously
that the
robot was a load of fun um scoring
against hungary the first time
but i don't think you'll ever be
representing your country in a world cup
yeah uh that first game against paraguay
uh in germany i always remember being a
you know the number nine for for england
that day
um it was never lost on me because you
know i remember my dad saying to me you
know think about how many kids play
football think of how many kids want to
play for england think of how many kids
want to play out front for england in a
world cup and at this particular day
that's you you know i mean like
is an amazing thing that
you know sometimes you i think after
your career you realize like oh yeah
that was not bad because goosebumps that
even just like punish your ass yeah
yeah amazing you know singing the anthem
in the world cup knowing thinking the
whole nation has stopped to watch this
particular match that you're involved in
um
yeah
i mean that was probably the
the best feeling um representing the
country here and you scored against
trinidad yeah that again as well like
yeah scoring a goal against
in a world cup as well um it just
things just just you don't realize the
magnitude and listen i've scored headers
loads of times right yeah and i just
that's all it was and i remember
obviously beckham great cross
me heading in bit of relief because we
should have been being trended out
anyway let's be honest um
and scoring and then obviously elation
of scoring but then the realization
afterwards is like of how many when you
see the you know the fan parks and
people with beers up in the air and you
realize that you've you know done that
um yeah that's special i think left over
that goes you had your hand on the guys
pointing to it
they asked me after the game about it
said what about the foul i was like what
are you talking about no no foul there
and then i went home and i set my hotel
room and i saw the goal
yeah
i was bad i i
i literally had no recollection of
pulling his dreadlocks but
i literally jumped up and just like
tried trying to get leverage i didn't
know he's a shirt or anything i didn't
know anyone saw it or anything and i
just obviously just grabbed something
and pulled and he beat his whole neck
back and yeah obviously it was a foul
but it's in the record books now
there's no one in our team thinking
score a winning goal no one can be
you know you've just got a goal you're a
leaf is is enormous and the second goal
goes in
and literally i'm planked on the floor
on my back
literally i think i actually nearly went
into tears
i was emotional screaming and to be fair
even now i feel quite emotional about it